Film Courage: What are the key steps in developing
a web series?
I know you’ve said before it’s not really
a film script so you can’t really divide
it up and just say great well these two pages
are going to be the first episode, you’ve
got to design it especially for that five
minute time period.
Kathie Fong Yoneda: The most important thing
is that you have to have a character that
you feel will hold the audiences interest
and he or she has to be involved in something
that is relatable.
So using something that is of personal interest
to the creator is probably one good way to
start.
Start with an area of expertise that you’re
good at.
There’s a guy named Ed and I’ve forgotten
his last name.
But he had a web series and his was about
a guy who was a chef.
And the guy…he could create great food,
with the women who just couldn’t do anything!
And what he did was start off with that premise
“What does a guy got to do?”
And the fact that he eventually became a chef,
shows his trial and error of him eventually
becoming a chef and eventually making contacts
and it’s very funny because one of his favorite
things is he goes to the same Sushi shop a
couple of times a week.
And the real reason he goes is not just because
he likes the Sushi but he has a crush on this
one gal who works there and unfortunately
he sees this Asian guy come in giving the
gal a hug and everything and saying all of
this and I missed you and everything.
And so he thinks “Oh my gosh, she’s got
a husband or a boyfriend.”
And she’s interested in him too.
And she flirts with him and always asking
him “How are you doing?”
It’s really cute.
And it turns out by the end of the first season
(I think the last episode) he finds out that
that’s her brother!
And then the love interest grows from that.
But it’s starting off with something maybe
an area that you know about like in his case
it was called, his web series is called PAIRINGS.
And you usually think of pairings as ‘Okay
what wine goes with this kind of dinner’
or whatever?
But it’s a play on words about what is was
like for this poor guy who’s a good cook
but just can’t see…he can cook everything
and anything but he just can’t seem to get
a gal.
Film Courage: But did he take this from his
own experience?
Was he or is he a chef?
Kathie: Yes.
And in fact he uses that as way to advertise
what he does is he’ll say “If you subscribe
to our web series” (and it doesn’t cost
anything to subscribe.
In his case it didn’t, you’ll get this
week’s recipes.
It’s something a little different which
kind of makes it interesting for the viewer
and the fans.
And as it turns out this guy (I think) is
going to be doing a cookbook.
And there is also an Olive Oil company I believe
and a winery that advertised now so he kind
of got sponsors from it.
So he didn’t purposely go out to do that.
When we were talking a little bit about “Well
I have to find a sponsor first.”
In this case the sponsor found him.
Film Courage: So built it and sort of that
Field of Dreams analogy but don’t set out
to have it be your only goal.
Kathie: And they’ll come.
Well if you don’t have the story, in his
case he was just fascinated by web series
and he always enjoyed writing and telling
stories and so for him to do that and his
day job was being a chef and he combined the
two of them.
And so there are no “Okay, first you do
this, this and this.”
It’s hard, it’s the same as any kind of
writing.
You’ve got to sit down, put your butt in
the chair and do it.
That’s the first step.
Most of the successful web series I’ve seen
a lot of them started off by taking a character
not unlike sometimes themselves and trying
to see Okay what’s the surrounding?
What’s the environment?
Another friend of mine did one, she’s lesbian.
And she noticed that there weren’t any lesbian
web series and she wanted to talk about the
fact that a lot of people don’t understand
that really that no matter what your sexuality
is people have stories and they have the same
fears and insecurities that all of go through
when we’re in a relationship.
And so she did one and it’s in Australia
and it’s called STARTING FROM NOW and it’s
becoming an Internet sensation.
They have fans all over the world and they
won a lot of awards.
But she took the world that she was in and
she thought how can I do something that’s
going to be interesting and have characters
that I think people are going to care about.
And when you look at it those characters,
they worry about their job just like we do,
they worry about what their families are going
to think just like we do, they worry about
what the political situations are like or
they worry about people cheating on them.
And you see all of those things playing out.
They are now finishing up (I think they may
have finished up) by now their fifth season,
so they’ve done incredibly well.
Film Courage: What’s the name of it again?
Kathie: STARTING FROM NOW and it’s based
in Australia but you can see it here, I mean
you can just Google it and it will come up.